what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Ali yes John Humphrey over here yeah
fragments that is evidences don't need
to be completed you know it doesn't need
to be complete is the film by Guillermo
del Toro we're going to see a part of
his latest film in the shape of water
today in the form of a trailer that's
what we're gonna boil is doing let's do
it all I know is Michael shun nanananana
is in it let's get gothic people if I
told you about her
the princess without voice
[Music]
she's down dude keep thinking you clean
that lab to get out this may very well
be the most sensitive aspects ever to be
housed in this building you may think
that they were human it stands on two
legs right we're created in the Lord Jim
you don't think that's what the Lord
looks like me
this creature is intelligent capable of
language of understanding emotions gobar
[Music]
her majority looks at me she doesn't
know so I am incomplete he even sees me
because I Oh
like Beauty and the Beast
[Music]
the natives in the Amazon worship it out
need to take it apart learn out I don't
want it in such a beautiful thing
destroyed did not I'm sorry just show
Michael Shannon died if I told you about
her water bring to life well guys the
prequel to a from hell here did you
cannot figure that when you see the
creatures of the black is that them jump
Abe Sapien he's like pyramid s really
might be Doug Jones he's credited to be
in the film actually I feel like if he's
got a character like that he's probably
got Jonas Laney like it's a virgin what
kind of design like him too and just so
there's no confusion we mention this in
a couple of videos already but because
it's comic-con week reactions and
reviews we've been putting them on
separate videos but it's gonna be in one
video for the week at comic-con yeah
this has everything that you love about
Guillermo del Toro when they first said
from the director of Pan's Labyrinth how
much he took so many more films enhanced
labyrinth since then but that seemed
like the perfect film to remind people
of what he's done when you see this
trailer yeah it has that fairytale de
ferrol fantasy vibe and then it goes
classic del Toro work like the end of
the trailers like oh it's kind of a
horror movie - yeah I am but period peas
and they are very fantastical but in a
in a scientific sort of scientific sort
of wind it does kind of have this beauty
in the beasts element of it tuna of a
human being falling in love with it with
a creature and knowing Karel del Toro he
could probably pull it off in a room
like I want these two I would need you
know their I want them to hook up idea
to this movie is important yeah I get
Egypt and Michael Shannon as
bad guy well yeah I mean Michaels had to
create bad guy when he did he intense
yeah but he's one of those guys who I'd
ever feel as a typecast bad guy but you
can expect him to be a bad guy however
he can always bring a different layer
because he is one of the best actors we
have around today and I think one of the
most underrated actors and I'm so
excited that he's in a guillermo del
toro film yeah totally I mean like he
always brings a really lived in quality
and this is a great cast Michael
Stuhlbarg I really like seeing and stuff
you know Richard Jenkins and Sally
Hawkins man is great and to see her take
on a role like this where you know she's
going to not speak for most of it I've
been really intrigued by that lately for
some reason like movies that aren't as
heavy I'm dialoguing on characters who
don't necessarily speak and stuff
I think it's intriguing because it's a
challenge for the audience even though
you know she's going to be doing sign
language and then we're going to be able
to read subtitles a lot of the time too
films become very heavy as expositional
dialogue and you're kind of limited in
that capacity when you have a character
has a mute but it also makes sense why
she in this creature who doesn't speak
English and communicate with each other
because they'll have to find ways to
communicate without verbally they don't
need language so it makes sense that
they can really connect with each other
I like the idea of this story of this
person works in a science lab with a
secret creature being there she starts
to fall for it and then you know you got
the government person like Michael
Shannon who's the one yo you can't trust
the creature and it does remind me it
doesn't remind me a lot of Pan's
Labyrinth actually when I think of it in
that capacity it's got the cultural
backdrop of the Cold War too because
yeah 60s and stuff like that I got
imagine you know you're taking place in
a government laboratory like this has to
bring some of that paranoia into there
and yeah you know distrust yeah this
seems like classic del Toro
I feel like crimson peak what let some
people down in terms of you what we want
from Guillermo del Toro and I know we
can spend time debating why that's
actually a good film or not yeah but
with that specific film I can see why
people were let down by it I feel like
all the elements that we want from del
Toro fantasy elements creature effects
period piece
horror and fuse with the love and
fantasy vodkas it feels like both those
elements are going to be very strong
here he has a very distinct way of
bringing
fantasy being lost in the fantasy and
then getting scared yeah yeah very few
directors can pull both of those
qualities off and I feel
del Toro is the one who could really do
this it seems that all the earmarks you
know the Guillermo del Toro moving it
seems like they're pitching it to be
what it is is what I hope for you know
crimson peak definitely was made to look
like a horror movie and this looks like
it has a lot of different elements when
you say like sci-fi fantasy drama like I
see that through this oh I see that sort
of gothic own he's so good at yeah
there's like a part of a Harry Potter
world at the same time - yeah yeah
there's anybody who could take on like
one of those like else world Harry
Potter stories and actually make it
special like Garamond El Toro I feel
like would be your guy all right guys
what are you going to see the shape of
water what's your favorite gamble del
Toro movie except for Pacific Rim
subscribe to the reel rejects become
part of the reject nation you click that
notification bell - on Humphry on
twitter and instagram social media
manager of Blum house calm and as always
make sure to check out our exclusive
perks and rewards over at patreon.com
slash the real rejects we'd love to have
you become a part of the community over
there it's growing and love all the
people that are participating in it you
want to put us on your body shots pretty
sure calm / the real rejects